[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui leurs
trompettes pour son roman la révérence
des éléphants qui traite de deux sujets
d'actualité le droit des personnes âgées
à mourir dans la dignité et le droit de
vivre dignement des éléphants d'afrique
je reçois également l'historien bruno
fuligni pour son livre victor hugo
président qui nous raconte le hugo
politique le hugo qui a rêvé pendant
trente ans de la magistrature suprême
entre deux best-sellers et qui a failli
plusieurs fois être candidat mais l'on
commence tout de suite par notre époque
qu'est ce qui caractérise ce début de
xxième siècle voici votre réponse en
images bruno fuligni
c'est victor hugo mais ça c'est plutôt
la fin du xixème
voici le passage je trouve cette photo
très moderne et puisqu'on parlait de
mourir dans la dignité il est mort très
dignement
donc nous sommes en 1885 le 22 mai et
mon victor hugo et photographié sur son
lit de mort alors ça pourrait paraître
monstrueux ça se faisait à l'époque
victor hugo a vu la naissance de la
photographie
c'est vraiment un contemporain de cette
invention et cette photo finalement est
très respectueuse
on voit à quel point les comment
dirais-je et contrastes sont accentuées
il a murmuré au moment d'entrer en
agonie c'était ici une combe à jour et
de la nuit et toute l'oeuvre de hugo et
est bâti sur ces grands contrastes c'est
ce duel à mort du jour et de la nuit de
la lumière et des ténèbres y compris ray
tout le sens évidemment métaphorique un
la nuit pour lui c'est l'ignorance c'est
le mal les deux étant totalement liés
donc cette photo est assez
extraordinaire et je trouve d'une grande
modernité
le victor hugo historique est mort mais
déjà il ya quelque chose de spirituel
qui émane de ceux de ce grand homme et
qui est un legs qu'il fait au présent
donc j'aime beaucoup cette photo qui
devrait être à cros et qui en fait à une
certaine légèreté et une modernité assez
surprenante je trouve
vous dites atroce mais il faut se
souvenir qu'à l'époque tout le monde
voulait photographier ces morts sur leur
lit de mort justement
pour en garder le souvenir très souvent
d'ailleurs parce que oui et puis parce
qu'à l'époque la photo avait quelque
chose d'un peu magique par exemple en
photographier ça paraît inconcevable
mais ont photographié les enfants mort
nés pour qu'il en reste quelque chose et
puis victor hugo n'était pas le seul à
s'intéresser au spiritisme aux esprits
on s'est demandé à un moment si la
photographie ne permettait pas de capter
des fluides et esprit des êtres
immatériels et c'est un peu l'impression
qu'on a avec ce rayon de lumière qui
semble littéralement émaner du
personnage on a l'impression d'être
entre demande entre le réel et
l'imaginaire entre le vivant et
l'univers des ombres l'univers de la
mort la photo à l'époque de lecteurs
ebook a encore une aura de magie
finalement et et évitant une au gua
considérable mais s'en va en parler tout
à l'heure c'est non seulement un immense
écrivain mais est considéré comme tel
par tout le monde mais en plus un homme
politique de première importance
alors maintenant la photo de laura
trompette plus plus énigmatique je dois
dire puisqu'on voit ce cet ours blancs
avec des visiteurs derrière une vitre de
quoi s'agit-il exactement
alors cette photo en fait représente 1 a
été prise dans un hôtel en chine qui a
décidé de mettre au centre de l'hôtel
des ours blancs la deux même si on n'en
voit qu'un sur la photo et le but c'est
que les gens puissent venir dormir dans
l'hôtel et avoir depuis leur chambre ou
depuis tous les espaces communs une vue
sur ces ours blancs enfermé autour de
leurs maigres piscine et de leurs sols
qui n'a rien de leur habitat naturel
évidemment et je trouve ça encore une
fois très révélateur de notre époque
c'est à dire surtout gens me dire encore
plus aujourd'hui après tout ce qu'on a
traversé pendant un an après avoir
entendu les humains se plaindre
de l'enfermement et du confinement
considérer qu'on peut encore aujourd'hui
faire ça des animaux et être là autour
d'eux avec les smartphones derrière les
vitres et il se réjouir finalement dans
cette rencontre qui n'en ai ping qui
n'est pas du tout une rencontre
c'est aberrant voilà sachant qu'en plus
énormément d'eau ont fait énormément de
progrès justement dans la bannière de de
garder les animaux en captivité et c'est
pas du tout comme ça effectivement qu'on
le perde leur permet de vivre le moins
mal possible leur captivité
mais on va en reparler tout de suite de
notre rapport aux animaux sauvages
commençons
[Musique]
alors dans la référence des éléphants
votre nouveau roman paru aux éditions
charleston vous fait un parallèle entre
une vieille dame malade dans un ehpad de
la ville de cannes et les matriarches
chez les éléphants de tanzanie ce sont
deux sujets d'actualité le droit de
mourir dans la dignité d'un côté les
éléphants d'afrique menacés de
disparition de l'autre parce qu'ils sont
vraiment menacée de disparition
aujourd'hui
mais quand ils en commun d'après vous
mais j'avais vraiment envie
voilà des traités ces deux sujets et ce
qu'ils ont en commun c'est le monde qui
rétrécit leur monde qui rétrécit c'est à
dire que évidemment marguerite donc mon
personnage de 93 ans qui est dans son
départ sont rétrécis dans cet ehpad ans
c'est un peu comme dans la chanson de
brel les vieux du nid du l'ironie
finalement vers la fin et est donc sonde
rétrécit et de l'autre côté dans le
roman on a le monde des éléphants qui
enfin le territoire des éléphants qui
rétrécit puisque ben on est très
nombreux sur terre aujourd'hui et à
mesure que le l'homme est toujours en
expansion permanente et bien les
éléphants et tout le monde sauvage a de
moins en moins d espace et j'avais envie
de faire un parallèle entre les deux à
travers cette histoire de la révérence
de l'éléphant alors va-t-on on pourrait
dire que depuis le néolithique au moment
où l'homme s'est sédentarisé qu'il a
inventé l'élevage et de l'agriculture
l'homme gagne du terrain sur la nature
et et c'est d'ailleurs en gagnant du
terrain qu'on a pu être de plus en plus
nombreux et vivre deux ans de plus en
plus vieux comme comme votre héroïne
dans son épave au fond 1
mais en même temps c'est vrai que les
animaux sauvages en sont les premières
victimes
leur territoire se rétrécir ce qui
concerne les éléphants d'afrique
les éléphants de la savane non plus que
le 15 pour 100 g a gardé le chiffre de
l'air qui leur était dévolu
historiquement et sa de graves
conséquences pour eux mais comment
l'arrêter à part avec de bons sentiments
comment arrêter cette progression de
l'humanité le fait qu'on ait de plus en
plus nombreux et qu'on a besoin de plus
en plus de place est-ce qu'on peut
l'arrêter
ça c'est une question très difficile
parce qu'effectivement il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas de réponse parfaite
il n'y a pas de réponse parfaite
aujourd'hui on pourrait commencer par
arrêter ce qui en dehors du territoire
met en danger leur vie comme par exemple
le braconnage
pour le reste c'est une question de bon
sens c'est à dire que il faut organiser
les choses pour que chacun puisse
trouver sa place et c'est un peu ce que
j'essaie de mettre en scène dans mon
roman
mais évidemment il n'ya pas une bonne
réponse je regardais d'autres chiffres
hier dans fin bref je suis tombé sur
d'autres chiffres ia qui disait que
l'homme et tous les animaux d'élevage
représente aujourd'hui 80 96 % de la
planète là où l'intégralité des espèces
sauvages représentent 4% 4%
donc voilà à mon donné il faut réaliser
que dans quelques années on en verra
plus que que dans des romans dans des
reportages passé et c'est pas possible
donc même si leur déclin semble
inexorable je pense que il ya beaucoup à
faire pour déjà prendre conscience et
puis essayer de répartir davantage les
les territoires et ça passe aussi par
effectivement une une prise de
conscience globale et une forme
d'éducation sur tous ces sujets là mais
en même temps quand on est votre roman
on y voit une alors je sais pas si vous
l'avez fait exprès mais mais moi j'ai vu
un rapport au fond
quand les animaux leur territoire se
rétrécit c'est le cas des éléphants en
afrique on vient de le dire pas
seulement de la savane d'ailleurs dans
la forêt c'est exactement la même chose
quand les animaux sont trop nombreux
dans un territoire de plus en plus
petits les conséquences sont se font
sentir à la fois sur la qualité de la
nourriture il y en a de moins en moins
donc sacré des affrontements ça a des
conséquences sur la reproduction et on
peut dire que leur génétique en fait en
souffrent - iliad éléphants sur un
territoire enfin plutôt sur un
territoire de plus en plus réduits le
fait que les éléphants sont de moins en
moins nombreux et leur diversité
génétique en souffrent et nous c'est
exactement l'inversé c'est à dire que
plus on a deux territoires et plus on a
des animaux d'élevage à notre
disposition plus on va vivre vieux et
plus on va se porter bien
le plus longtemps possible et au fond le
destin de cette vieille dame ressemble
au destin de plus en plus de gens dans
notre humanité pas seulement en occident
qui vont vivre de plus en plus vieux
grâce à ce phénomène oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai que dire je pense que
effectivement la population est
vieillissante
en tout cas chez nous et des tas
d'autres pays et le problème de sa fin
ce que j'ai voulu vraiment abordé dans
mon roman
c'est ce naufrage de la vieillesse avec
j'espère le plus de réalisme possible et
tout ce qu'on essaye d'y mettre comme
distraction un peu factice et qui
finalement sont une sorte de
d'infantilisation aussi deux de ces
êtres humains qui quand il doit encore
tout leur toutes leurs capacités
cérébrales sont démunis face à cette
infantilisation c'est quelque part une
chance une forme de aussi de non pas
d'augmenter respect mais en tout cas
c'est difficile pour eux ils ont vécu
toute une vie et ils se retrouvent ils
se retrouvent à l'état d'enfant presse
donc ça c'est c'est une partie de
l'histoire et l'autre partie c'est c'est
vraiment ce choix de mourir dans la
dignité qui était
un mais deux sujets principaux et
j'avais envie de rappeler que la france
ce droit ne nous appartient toujours pas
et donc il appartient pas à marguerite
qui est pourtant à 93 ans et non vie a
enterré beaucoup trop de monde après ses
intérêts tous les gens qu'elle
connaissait et et souhaiterait pouvoir
choisir son art et son moment pour pour
partir et et c'est pas possible en
france
alors vous nous en aux éléphants parce
que vous avez fait un très beau travail
vais regarder vraiment absolument toutes
les facettes du problème des éléphants
en train de disparaître en afrique alors
d'abord le leur pire ennemi évidemment
ce sont les braconniers et les
braconniers travail pour qui les
braconniers c'est ça c'est qu'en fait
c'est ce que j'explique dans le roman
c'est celle au bout de la chaîne c'est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler les petites
mains et la chaîne est très longue il
travaillait pour qui alors
la chine a rendu illégal l'import export
de enfin le le commerce de l'ivoire
depuis quelques années pour autant le
commerce illégal existe toujours en
chine dans des pays d'asie et même pas
là par ailleurs dans certains pays
d'auray et donc c'est une très longue
chaîne avec énormément de corruption
donc si on détaille à chaque étape ce
sera long mais mais en tout cas
effectivement le braconnier c'est pas
celui qui va gagner le plus c'est celui
qui prend le plus de risques et c'est
celui qui est toujours pointé du doigt
alors que les gens qui tient les
ficelles sont très très grand est et on
les voit pas il ya aussi les les
villageois dont la quiétude des
bouleversées par le passage des
éléphants un peu comme ce que l'on
connaît nous en france quand on a
réintroduit le nous
l'ours évidemment les villageois les
berges et les cultivateurs n'ont pas vu
ça d'un très bon oeil
en afrique c'est pareil les les les
habitants de la savane n'aime pas
beaucoup les éléphants alors c'est vrai
que c'est plus marrant c'est que ça
c'est que c'est pas tant qu'ils n'aiment
pas beaucoup les éléphants c'est que ça
crée des conflits ça dès qu'on crée des
conflits pour l'eau ça crée des conflits
parce que lorsque les éléphants sont
attirés par l'odeur du grand mur ils
font des charges est effectivement et
piétinent les champs il piétine parfois
une partie des villages et sacré de gros
problèmes
est-ce que j'ai vraiment essayé de
montrer à travers la révérence de
l'éléphant c'est que pour moi le enfin
il faut pas traiter la chose de manière
malik espère qu on a pas d'un côté les
villageois qui en veulent aux éléphants
et de l'autre côté les éléphants qui qui
ne font rien de terrible s'est pas aussi
simpliste que ça l'idée c'est c'est
enfin ce que je voulais montrer c'est
qu'effectivement il ya un conflit que
les éléphants ils ont des chemins
ancestraux
c'est ça aussi le parallèle que je
voulais faire dans le roman entre
marguerite cette grand mère qui a guidé
sa ligne et khalid et son petit-fils et
les matriarches en fait qui guide la
lignée de faire le système des éléphants
et matriarcale l'organisation de
matriarcale et donc ils apprennent aux
petits éléphants entre guillemets les
les chemins ancestraux et la manière de
vivre
et quand certains villages se sont
installés sur ces chemins ancestraux
malheureusement on a un problème alors
il ya des manières de les détourner et
là je pense qu'il ya des tas de
solutions pacifiques qui existe il ya
évidemment les qu'on appelle du chili
bombes qui sont peut-être pour éloigner
les éléphants mais il ya aussi les
ruches d'abeilles
certes les les éléphants n'aime pas ça
et donc si on installe alors bien sûr ça
a un coût en tout ça un peu le tout ce
qui pourrait éloigner les éléphants des
villages et des chants de monde aux gens
d'avoir certains moyens et de pouvoir
s'organiser mais effectivement
l'installation de ruches et très
efficace parfois aussi
mais de la vanille ou quelque chose qui
à l'index les attire ailleurs pour
pouvoir détourner les détourner des
villages et modifier leurs trajectoires
donc il ya des tas de choses à mettre en
place finalement pour que la
cohabitation puisse être plus pacifiques
alors parmi les les alliés il ya les
rangers c'est évidemment qui eux sont
chargés de la protection des éléphants
ça va de soi et qui parfois risquent
leur vie pour y parvenir il vous le
raconter très bien il ya aussi les
chasseurs parce que au fond il ya une
chasse légale qui peut-être et vous le
montrez bien aussi un mal nécessaire
exactement à titre personnel je ne peux
absolument pas défendre la chasse mais à
travers mon roman j'avais envie
effectivement montré tous les propos et
il est traité de façon la plus juste
possible à travers mes personnages
et effectivement les chasseurs eux ne
s'attaque qu'à des mâles dans d'un
certain âge ne vont pas tuer ni femelle
ni très jeune éléphant est par ailleurs
ben il ya un côté protection c'est à
dire que le chasseur qui va sur son
action prendre chez nous le match est
celle où ces immenses le chasseur va
préserver quelque part son gibier c'est
terrible de dire ça comme ça mais ils
ont aussi une manière de chasser qui
n'est pas la même
évidemment que les braconniers et
quelque part comme les territoires sont
immenses et qu'il n'y a pas assez de
ranger pour couvrir ces territoires
c'est tout le problème est d'ailleurs
vous disiez les rangers risque parfois
leur vie dans les rangers risque très
souvent leur vie
il ya devant tous les partenaires you
know on a les noms de tous ceux qui ont
perdu la vie en essayant de protéger les
animaux et donc c'est en ce sens que les
chasseurs ont quelque part un rôle à
jouer contre le braconnage
en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'ils s'en
défendent après il ya aussi un autre
autre chose c'est que la chasse rapporte
de l'argent
la chasse légale là où le braconnage ne
fait que publier les rochelle et les
ressources et la noblesse de ce pays en
l'occurrence la tanzanie
sans sans rien apporter oui mais alors
les meilleurs alliés se sont quand même
les touristes parce que l'ajustement les
éléphants représente une valeur
économique considérable quand on va au
kenya en tanzanie en namibie
ce que l'on veut voir ce sont des
éléphants et si demain il devait avoir
disparu y aurait probablement beaucoup
moins de touristes
donc là on voit bien que en ayant une
valeur économique
au fond le l'éléphant a une chance de
s'en sortir
à la différence du requin par exemple le
requin c'est le pire ennemi des
touristes les touristes lui en ont très
très peur et pour les rassurer on tue
des requins alors que les requins tu
très très peu de touristes
l'éléphant c'est le contraire et son
meilleur ami c'est le touriste ouais bon
alors juste pour revenir sur cette
histoire de requins ce que vous tendez
une pêche le peut-être que le rockeur
est considéré comme le pire ennemi des
touristes marfaing le pire ennemi du
jour aucun ça reste l'homme et la pêche
industrielle mais ça c'est un autre
débat est donc l'éléphant l'éléphant a
effectivement besoin quelque part des
touristes parce que le les parcs
nationaux donc les parcs nationaux
il ya une différence entre parcs
nationaux réserves et aires de
conservation et les parcs nationaux sont
des endroits réservés aux animaux dans
lesquels on ne peut pas habiter n'y a
pas de cohabitation entre l'homme et
l'animal a trait à l'intérieur des parcs
nationaux et il n'y a pas de chasse
autorisés à l'intérieur des parcs
nationaux
contrairement aux réserves et donc ses
parcs nationaux effectivement qui sont
souvent parfois par des gens qui ne
connaissent pas les parcs nationaux sont
perçus comme des enclos ce ne sont pas
les enclos en tanzanie par exemple il ya
des corridors entre différents parcs
nationaux pour permettre cette grande
migration et pour permettre aux animaux
de 2,2 de bouger dans l'espace et bien
sûr à travers la visite des enfants tout
cas le fait que les touristes vont dans
ces parcs nationaux permet de rapporter
de l'argent au pays aux parcs nationaux
de façon à payer les rangers et
préserver cet espace qui leur reste
encore puisque à l'intérieur il n'y a
pas de problème de cohabitation et donc
de demander ce passe mais c'est vrai que
c'est le par ailleurs les parcs
nationaux et on en avait parlé dans
cette émission pose un autre problème
c'est que effectivement l'homme ne peut
plus habiter dans les parcs nationaux
c'est entièrement laissée à la vie
sauvage met pas la même occasion on a
carrément exilés des gens qui habitaient
là depuis très longtemps et qui ont dû
partir et parfois dans la souffrance des
endroits qu'ils habitaient depuis des
générations et qu'on a fait le choix des
animaux à ce moment là au détriment des
humains alors ça peut choquer mais
justement c'est une des questions
choquant que vous abordez dans votre
roman
c'est la question du choix entre l'homme
et l'animal
au fond et il ya des discussions entre
certains de vos personnages et il y en a
qui qui proclame qui contraint un
éléphanteau et un enfant il choisirait
de sauver l'éléphant et pour une raison
simple et quasiment mathématiques c'est
que les éléphants sont en voie de
disparition donc n'importe quel membre
de l'espèce doit être préservé les
humains n'étant pas encore en voie de
disparition
évidemment ils doivent s'incliner devant
les éléphants reste une vraie question
philosophique ce alors c'est vrai qu'ils
sont philosophique
si vous me permettez de nuance un petit
peu mon personnage ou c'est emmanuel le
personnage photographe animalier de mon
roman qui est qui évolue en tanzanie
lui il trouve 7 comparé au moment de
cette conversation avec peter le
scientifique qui lui dit qu'on ne peut
que choisir entre un éléphanteau et un
enfant un enfant massaï par exemple
enfants tanzaniens de manière générale
ou avec manu ou un enfant occidentales
soient frais de même bien sûr mais pour
reprendre ce qui se passe on roman
emmanuel trouve la question choquant crp
là où la plupart des gens considèrent
puisque c'est mon impression en tout cas
que il est évident que la vie humaine se
place au dessus de la vie animale
ce n'est pas du tout mon opinion pour
moi il n'y a pas de hiérarchisation
entre les deux et bien c'est aussi le
point de vue de mon personnage emmanuel
qui qui trouve la question de choquant
et qui pensent que les deux doivent
exister mais non il ne choisit
évidemment pas l'éléphanteau il
considère simplement que le fait de
devoir choisir entre les deux ce n'est
pas un produit ce n'est pas une question
ce n'est pas possible c'est par choix
par des nuances s'éteint c'est par choix
impossible voilà c'est plutôt ça c'est
plutôt son point de vue et bien sûr je
sais que c'est choquant parce qu'ils y
aillent
j'ai même des lecteurs qui m'ont dit que
enfin une lectrice en particulier qui
m'a été choqués par ce passé par cette
comparaison et par le fait de ne pas
évidemment choisir l'enfant est
aujourd'hui c'est une question de point
de vue
l'humain depuis très longtemps depuis
toujours se place en haut de la chaîne
alimentaire
ce place voilà en premier estime qu il
est au dessus de tout ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas ce que je pense pour moi la
vie animale
autant de valeurs et de prix que la vie
humaine mais vous restez là dans le dans
le domaine vous vous engagez pas au fond
mais en réalité il faut bien le savoir
aujourd'hui dans sa robe de pays
d'afrique et donc c'est ce que vous
venez de décrire la vie d'un éléphant
est plus précieuse que la vie d'un
enfant quel que soit cet enfant parce
que on veut préserver les éléphants
qu'ils sont en danger et que donc on
accorde c'est encore plus choquant que
ce que vous dites c'est à dire alors
choquant ou pas d'ailleurs moi je ne
trouve pas ça choquant puisque je veux
que les éléphants perdure donc je sais
que pour cela il faut être prêt à
sacrifier le confort ou parfois même la
vie des humains on accepte que un
éléphant puce piétiner un village et
donc éventuellement tué par accident un
enfant on ne voudrait pas l'un vers cela
vers ce serait plus grave alors
évidemment dès l'instant on connaît
l'enfant c'est totalement différent
on veut tous choisir l'enfant mais mais
statistiquement c'est le choix qui a été
fait aujourd'hui pour préserver les
animaux sauvages et ce serait vrai aussi
pour un ours ou pour autre chose
offrez-lui pas vraiment parce que dans
les faits évidemment quand un éléphant
50 les rangers vont intervenir aux
abords d'un parc national et qu' il ya
un conflit entre l'éléphant et des
villageois
le but n'est évidemment pas de tir et
l'éléphant en revanche il ya quelques
mois un éléphant s'est approché darche
alors c'est quelque chose que j'ai sur
moi dans ma vie personnelle s'est pas
passé à la télévision mais un éléphant
s'est approché de da rocha a tué
quelqu'un a tué un homme
j'ai pas les circonstances exactes mais
il semblerait que l'homme se soit trop
approché le d'éléphants l'éléphant a été
abattu l'éléphant été abattus découpés
et et sa viande
c'est enfin probablement servi à nourrir
des gens donc aujourd'hui bien qu'il ya
un travail fantastique de préservation
notamment dans tout l'espace du gros
gros
mais pas mais pas seulement dans tout le
nord tanzanian il ya vraiment une
volonté de préserver la vie animale pour
autant lorsque c'est la vie animale où
la vie humaine le choix qui est en
parfait aujourd'hui en tout cas à la
connaissance avec toutes les recherches
que j'ai pu faire et ce que j'ai pu
observer
ça reste le chemin oui quand c'est alors
moi je dis rennes j'ai l'impression que
quand c'est individuel
voilà on connaît l'éléphant on connaît
l'humain qui a été tué par l'éléphant et
on abat l'éléphant honda base cet
individu là qui s'est rendu coupable de
la mort de cet individu là mais quand on
fait des choix
je dirais presque au niveau national
c'est très différent
les deux ne pèse pas de la même manière
parce que les uns sont moins rares
menacées d'extinction et pas les autres
si demain les hommes sont menacées
d'extinction
on changera vraisemblablement de
politique
merci en tout cas le rat trompette la
révérence de l'éléphant c'est un très
beau titre d'ailleurs puisque il dit
bien ce que ce que vous voulez dire
la révérence de l'éléphant votre nouveau
roman est paru aux éditions charleston
on se retrouve juste après une pause
avec bruno fuligni qui publie victor
hugo président ça n'est pas un titre
provocateur il a vraiment voulu être
président
[Musique]
bruno fuligni vous êtes historien et le
titre de votre nouveau livre victor hugo
président qui vient de paraître chez
publicis est tout à fait sérieux le
grand écrivain français du 19e siècle
rêvais d'être président il a failli se
présenter deux fois il a été père de
france maire du viiie arrondissement de
paris députés en 1848 opposant numéro un
napoléon iii à son retour triomphal
d'exil en 1870 s'il pense vraiment qu'il
a une chance
il est réélu député puis sénateur il est
vraiment la figure tutélaire de la
république à cette époque pourtant vous
le raconter dans votre livre il n'était
pas du tout républicain au départ un
victor hugo jeune il était légitimiste
puis bonapartiste puis orléaniste et il
était très à droite oui victor hugo a
changé plusieurs fois de drapeaux et on
pourrait considérer qu'il était un petit
peu opportuniste mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ses idées elles
ont peu changé par exemple qu'il soit un
royaliste bonapartiste ou républicain ou
même se réclamant du socialisme à la fin
il a toujours été opposé à la peine de
mort sous tous les régimes
quelles que soient les configurations il
a comme cela quelques quelques combats
qui traverse sa vie en fait victor hugo
s'est d'emblée conçu comme une puissance
politique à lui tout seul et il a
cherché à nouer des alliances dans un
premier temps et il était jeune il a
pensé que le grand poète qu'il était
pourrait conseiller une tête couronnée
et qu'il y aurait un roi roi de france 3
des français un nouvel empereur
peut-être qui écouterait ses conseils et
quincy en tant que poète et que maje il
inspirait la vie politique qu'il
inspirait la décision politique en étant
un petit peu le deuxième cerveau du
monarque et puis c'est déçu par un
certain nombre d'expériences des chaînes
de ce point de vue là qu'il va
s'orienter vers autre chose et lui qui
était plutôt à la base réactionnaire
va s'intéresser à la république parce
que avec la république et avec le
suffrage universel qui est proclamée en
finalement le poète peut être candidat
peut se présenter devant le peuple le
souverain
ça n'est plus un individu c'est une
collectivité humaine qui au fond fait
bon accueil à ces heurts dont pourrait
faire aussi bon accueil à ses idées et
donc il s'adresse au peuple en tant qu
il s'adresse aux souverains pour dire eh
bien voilà moi j'incarne une politique
j'incarne une solution j'incarne un
programme finalement qu'il aimerait
mettre en application et effectivement
il a vraiment pensé être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle alors à deux
reprises d'abord à l'élection
présidentielle de décembre 1848 la
république est proclamée en février avec
le suffrage universel
on met en place de nouvelles
institutions il est question d'élire
pour la première fois en france un
président au suffrage universel direct
évidemment masculin en 1848 mais enfin
suffrage universel direct et il envisage
de se présenter
l'ironie de l'histoire c'est que assez
vite et un candidat qui sort un peu du
lot qui était un peu inattendu c'est
louis napoléon bonaparte qui porte ce
nom magique et à d'emblée un certain
succès et donc ils se désistent victor
hugo et ils se rallient à ce candidat
dans un premier temps ce qu'on a oublié
c'est que celui que plus tard il
appellera napoléon le petit et à qui il
va s'opposer de façon très très net dans
un premier temps et bien c'est un allié
il se désiste en sa faveur il fait
campagne en sa faveur
ils votent pour lui en 1848 évidemment
les deux hommes vont s'éloigner
victor hugo va trouver puis oui il mène
une politique beaucoup trop
réactionnaire il passe beaucoup trop de
choses à l'église mais oui ap orléans
bonaparte en 1848 n'est-il que pour
quatre ans ainsi la durée du mandat
présidentiel à l'époque un petit peu à
l'imitation des américains et donc côté
victor hugo bah il prépare
tranquillement l'échéance électorale de
1852 en disant voilà j'aime et j'ai eu
tort de me désister
je suis déçu par le candidat et j'ai
soutenu je m'éloigne de lui il réussit
quand même à prendre la tête de
l'opposition de gauche qui n'était pas
si simple puisqu'il ya une assemblée
nationale où il siège et en particulier
sur des questions de laïcité de
l'enseignement il devient une des
grandes voix de 2,7 de cette gauche
républicain simplement l'élection des
852 n'aura jamais lieu
parce que en décembre 1851 le 2 décembre
dégâts ce fameux coup d'état par lequel
louis napoléon bonaparte supprime
l'assemblée nationale s'empare de toutes
les commandes et un an plus tard il se
proclame empereur sous le nom de
napoléon iii et c'est à partir de ce
moment là qui va y avoir ce duel bien
connus ou victor hugo en exil défi
napoléon le petit mais c'est à l'issue
de tout un processus
et pendant cet exil finalement victor
hugo ne préside pas mais il personnifie
la république pour tous les républicains
vaincus pour tous les républicains qui
estiment honteux ce régime issu d'un
coup d'état par un président au fond
parjure qui devait garantir les
institutions et qui s'est emparée du
pouvoir
victor hugo c'est un recours et c'est la
grande voie qui proclame ce crime
politique qu'a été le coup d'état et y
compris les nenê victime qui l'a qu'il a
causés sur le pavé parisien et et
ailleurs parce qu'il ya eu des révoltes
contre le coup d'état est ce qui fait
que victor hugo en exil et c'est ça
aussi qui explique sa constance dans
l'exil
ces 18 années qu'il va passer à malgré
les amnisties malgré des propositions
qui va passer à l'étranger et en
particulier à guernesey et bien c'est
qu'il pense que le jour où le second
empire s'écroulera et ce jour viendra
c'est lui qu'on plébiscitera président
donc en 1870 encore en qu'il revient en
france que napoléon iii est prisonnier
des crucial de son régime s'est effondré
littorio s'imaginent qu'on va lui
confier les rênes de l'état évidemment
l'histoire va être complètement
différente mais il va rester le grand
inspirateur de cette troisième
république et qui n'est
dans la difficulté à ce moment là alors
ce qui est très intéressant
dans votre livre et est fier victor-hugo
d'abord il faut bien comprendre que
victor hugo c'est pas un écrivain qui a
la tête qui explose c'est pas jean edern
hallier qui se croient l'opposant numéro
1 de françois mitterrand d'abord sa
stature de poètes d'écrivain est
absolument considérable et pas seulement
en france
ces tirages ses best-sellers sont
absolument dingue quand sortent les
misérables
ça sort en même temps alors qu'il est en
exil ça sera paris à londres à rio de
janeiro à vienne moscou
c'est ce sont des livres c'est très
important victor hugo dont qu'il a il a
les moyens de ses ambitions
on pourrait dire et puis c'est un vrai
penseur politique vous l'avez dit qui
pense toujours au fond la même chose
sous des régimes différents à la fois
sous louis philippe il est quasiment le
meilleur ami ce que j'ignorais du prince
héritier du fils de louis-philippe donc
il a priori devrait succéder à son père
donc là il peut se penser comme
inspirateur du prochain monarque et mais
ils pensent la même chose quasiment que
quand il revient d'exil en 1870 ça
poutre de la gauche radicale meilleur
ami des communards salle empêche pas
dans les deux cas d'être par exemple un
ardent défenseur de la propriété privée
de la nation de la vie humaine vous
l'avez dit
il a comme ça des convictions qui
transcende
c'est son opportunisme entre guillemets
politique
l'exigence de civilisation la recherche
de l'équilibré social c'est quelque
chose qu'il aura toute sa vie et quand
il dit qu'on pourrait éradiquer la
pauvreté
il le dit à un moment il aurait pu le
dire au fils de louis philippe
oui peut-être d'ailleurs l'at-il
pressenti au temps de louis philippe et
il le dit clairement
lorsqu'il est représentant du peuple
c'est le titre des députés entre 1848 et
la fin de l'année 1851 il explique qu'on
peut supprimer la misère à et lorsque
plus tard il va intitulé l'un de ses
grands roman les misérables
c'est une réminiscence de cet engagement
là c'est à dire qu'il a l'idée que
l'état peut intervenir que ne supprimera
pas la souffrance il le dit c'est pas un
rêveur la souffrance c'est une loi
divine dit il
elle fait partie de la vie on on pourra
jamais supprimer la la la souffrance
mais la douleur là d'où la douleur on
pourra pas la supprimer
mais la misère la misère oui la misère
sociale à laquelle il assiste et victor
hugo est vraiment à traverser tout le
19e siècle et donc la révolution
industrielle qui plus est à paris une
ville qui a explosé sous l'effet de
l'exode rural et il voit les effets de
cette révolution industrielle
cet afflux de population dans une ville
qui n'est pas fait pour pour accueillir
ces personnes qui arrivent des campagnes
qui arrive d'assez loin qui gagnent leur
vie très difficilement dans une
industrie est totalement impitoyable bon
un système dans lequel il n'y a
évidemment aucun filet de sécurité nous
trouvons normal aujourd'hui lorsque nous
sommes malades et bien d'être en arrêt
maladie et de ne pas pour autant perdre
tous nos moyens d'existence évidemment
c'est pas victor hugo qui a conçu cela
mais il a imaginé que ça puisse exister
et à l'époque où ils l'annoncent ça fait
presque sourire ça paraît aberrant de la
même façon quand on parle de
l'école gratuite et de l'enseignement
public de l'enseignement obligatoire
on pense à jules ferry mais bien avant
jules-ferry 30 ans avant jules ferry
hugo explique que c'est possible que on
peut créer un système dans lequel tous
les enfants de france y compris ceux qui
vont à l'usiné parce qu'il n'est
contemporain du travail des enfants et
bien tous les enfants de france pourront
aller à l'école et bien dans des écoles
privées si les parents peuvent les pays
mais dans des écoles publiques et
gratuites
dans le cas contraire et à l'époque on
voit bien parce que vous savez quand un
orateur s'exprime dans une assemblée
parlementaire il ya un compte rendu de
ce qu'il déclare et puis entre
parenthèses en italie que vous avez les
applaudissements ou les réactions
positives ou négatives
et on voit qu'au moment où ils les noms
ces idées là il ya des murmures des
doutes parfois des ricanements tout ça
ne paraît pas sérieux en 1850
ça va devenir un peu sérieux trente ans
plus tard avec une ferry et puis
aujourd'hui nous ne concevons pas une
société qui ne proposerait pas une école
gratuite aux enfants qui n'ont pas
évidemment de famille suffisamment riche
pour leur payer une école payant donc
c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi dans
le hugo politique c'est que lorsqu'il se
présente comme un mage comme un
visionnaire ça pour préparer est
totalement mégalo mais en réalité
effectivement il entrevoit au delà de la
réalité ce que l'on pourrait construire
ce que l'on pourrait faire concrètement
dans ce monde là pour améliorer
la vie sociale pour améliorer la vie des
gens pour donner une chance aux enfants
pour autant il n'est pas révolutionnaire
au sens où il ne veut pas la
collectivisation il ne veut pas et
présente la commune
il ne soutient pas directement la
commune il est légaliste
en revanche après la répression de la
commune il est horrifié par ce qu'il a
vu encore une guerre civile
encore de l'injustice encore de la
noirceur et il va militer ça sera son
dernier combat pour l'amnistié des
communards communards qu'ils n'ont pas
été tué ceux qui ont été envoyé au bagne
en nouvelle calédonie ceux qui ont dû
fuir et qui vivent dans l'exil lui-même
ayant connu l'exil eh bien il va se
battre pour que soit votée une loi qui
permette à tous et communards de rentrer
de rentrer en france
et il va avoir bien de cause au sénat ça
sera vraiment son tout dernier combat en
1881 il faut savoir que l'amnistié des
communards et voter en même temps que
l'institution du 14 juillet comme fête
nationale en france c'est à dire que
lorsque nous fêtons 14 juillet nous
fêtons plein de choses dans 14 juillet y
compris la réunion finalement des
français la fin de cette guerre civile
qui a été la commune
l'amnistié des communards est donc là la
cicatrisation d'une des grandes
blessures du 19e siècle france ô ce qui
est intéressant aussi dans la
trajectoire de victor hugo homme
politique c'est lé moment où ne se
produit pas ce qui l'attendait et
alors la première fois on pourrait dire
il vous l'avait raconté comment il s'est
rallié à louis napoléon bonaparte en en
1848 emea sont à sa disposition le
journal que dirige ses deux fils qui
vont faire campagne pour pour hba n'a
pas bonaparte est élu et il attend
quelque chose à ce moment là victor hugo
il attend un ministère il faut bien le
dire il voudrait être ministre et et
louis napoléon bonaparte ne lui propose
que l'ambassade à naples alors ça à
l'époque le royaume des deux d'appeler
des deux siciles c'est une grande
puissance
enfin quand même c'est pas terrible
après lui propose une autre ambassade
mais c'est pas assez non plus il voulait
être ministre là on voit bien que
quelque chose aurait pu se produire
imaginons victor hugo faisant partie du
gouvernement domine napoléon bonaparte
donc démocratique à ce moment là ça
aurait peut-être changé quelque chose
oui là c'est une belle uchronie à
imaginer victor hugo ministre de louis
napoléon bonaparte
bon il a soutenu mais napoléon bonaparte
on lui propose une première ambassade
vous l'avez dit n'en veut pas on lui
propose du coup l'ambassade d'espagne
ce n'est pas rien surtout à l'époque
c'est très prestigieux et puis son père
à victor hugo a servi en espagne donc
symboliquement c'est aussi un beau geste
on pense qu'il va accepter avec
reconnaissance mais en fait il ya eu une
incompréhension totale entre louis
napoléon bonaparte qui fait de la
politique
je dirais assez politicienne et puis
victor hugo s'est par ailleurs victor
hugo
il est un petit peu tout seul lui se
conçoit comme une puissance politique
mais il a peu de troupes derrière lui
son journal est animé par ses fils il a
une petite phalange de fanatiques on va
dire à de gens qui le soutiennent mais
qui sont très peu nombreux ça pèse pas
très lourd entre d'autres forces
les maîtres de forges par exemple à dire
le lobby des industriels l'église
catholique l'église catholique qui a été
très inquiète de voir revenir la
république et donc d'activer toutes
sortes de souvenirs de la révolution
française
l'église et les notables de quels
soutiens ont réussi à faire élire louis
napoléon bonaparte en faisant voter les
campagnes pour ce candidat qui avait un
nom si rassurant l'église veut
maintenant reprendre le terrain perdu et
en particulier reprendre le contrôle de
l'enseignement et par là des consciences
avec l'idée que si on veut éviter de
nouvelles révolutions il faut vraiment
que ce soit les prêtres qui dirige
d'enseignement pour victor hugo c'est
insupportable cette idée il a été élevé
par des parents qui ont baigné dans
l'univers de la révolution française
lorsqu'il était enfant en espagne il a
été inscrit comme protestant ce que ses
parents n'étaient pas parce qu'on
voulait lui éviter le catéchisme il
s'est construit
il est religieux pour torah c'est pas un
âne à t il et anticlérical mais il est
religieux
il dira même sur son humeur là encore
grande constance je crois en dieu mais
lui oppose dieu au clergé pour lui dieu
il me tutoie d'un certain point de vue
dans certaines de ces de ces grandes
poésie et il ne comprend pas il n'admet
pas que des curés des petits prêtre
comme ceux là prétendent interpréter et
la pensée de dieu et l'utilisé surtout à
des fins politiques politiciennes de
contrôle social et senna que louis
napoléon bonaparte finalement sommé de
choisir entre l'énorme puissance qu'est
l'église catholique et victor hugo a
vite fait son choix
évidemment les gouvernements
de louis napoléon bonaparte vont être
très cléricaux et victor hugo va se
trouver petit à petit rejetés vers le
centre puis vers l'opposition
je pense que s'il avait été nommé
ministre de la même manière il aurait
fini par démissionner ils doivent a fini
par démissionner parce que sa position
n'était pas tenable
il ya eu un quiproquo lui rêvait d'un
bonaparte héritier du bonaparte général
de la révolution est en fait il a il
avait déjà napoléon iii qui voulait un
nouvel empire et un empire ainsi sur les
forces conservatrices
alors ensuite il revient en 1870 c'est
là il revient renforcée il est il est
beaucoup plus à gauche
sa période dans l'opposition de napoléon
iii l'a véritablement rendu beaucoup
plus à gauche il se réclame même du
socialisme il son retour est absolument
triomphal quand il vient à paris il
repart presque tout de suite vous de
parler de la commune mais il est en
belgique qu'aux mamans de la commune et
et son soutien aux communards après la
commune va lui valoir d'être expulsé de
belgique est de se retrouver au
luxembourg donc c'est un choix mais
qu'est ce qui fait qu'à ce moment là au
début de la troisième république lui qui
est si populaire et qui a vu quasiment
raison surtout qu'est ce qui fait qu'il
ne se passe rien alors évidemment il va
être élu député il va même être élu
sénateur
mais au fond il ne se passe pas ce qu'il
espérait qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là et est peut-être
d'ailleurs de mieux valu qu'il ne se
passe rien mais mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
loupé la en d'abord il a vieilli il a
passé 18 ans en exil
bien sûr il est universellement connus
et les républicains français
le connaissent ses oeuvres même les
pamphlets contre napoléon iii ont
circulé sous le manteau en petit format
réduit
il est universellement connu et il est
très admiré des républicains français
mais c'est un vieil homme
et puis c'est un homme qui a perdu le
contact avec la société française qui a
évolué et en particulier dans l'est
républicain
il ya une nouvelle génération des gens
qui étaient des petits enfants qui
étaient mineures voire qu'il n'était pas
né en 1848 des gens comme comme
clemenceau par exemple cette nouvelle
génération qui est bénie des lectures de
hugo qui va citer hugo pour montrer à
quel point ba dengue est à dire napoléon
iii était d'un criminel et n'avait aucun
droit au pouvoir
mais cette génération là elle a aussi un
projet elle veut bien comment dirais-je
salué le combat de victor hugo et salué
sa stature mais elle n'imagine pas de le
porter au pouvoir
ce sont donc des républicains d'une
autre génération qui vont arriver aux
commandes
et quant à victor hugo on va lui
proposer en croyant l'honorer
la mairie du xième arrondissement donc
imaginez là encore le quiproquo énorme
il revient en france est effectivement
un candidat rim gare du nord il est
passé par la belgique donc ils arrivent
gare du nord il ya une foule immense qui
l'attend on s'attelle à la charrette qui
va l'amener le ramener chez lui il n'ya
rien une liesse extraordinaire à cet
instant là s'il avait demandé à ce qu'on
compte plus à l'élysée il aurait sans
doute eu un mouvement de foule mais il
est légaliste
donc il attend qu'on l'appelle et ça en
politique ça arrive rarement un con
qu'on vienne vous chercher pour vous
donner le pouvoir
faut quand même se battre un petit peu
la réalité du pouvoir va être occupé par
d'autres et donc on lui propose la
mairie du xième arrondissement
évidemment il refuse et l'
incompréhension totale
alors au bout de quelques temps tout de
même
bon mais républicains vont comprendre
qu'ils aspirent à un peu plus alors
lui-même et élus représentants du peuple
mais il démissionne presque
immédiatement en 1871 l'assemblée
essentiellement monarchiste ils sont peu
nombreux
l'assemblée refuse de valider l'élection
de garibaldi lui trouve vraiment
scandaleux donc il démissionne mais
pareil il est persuadé qu'il va pouvoir
se représenter et être réélu à une
époque où en plus on peut se présenter
dans plein de départements en même temps
donc pourquoi pas un plébiscite
mais en fait le temps le moment la grâce
est pas passé et il va être battu il va
être battu en 1872 très humiliant donc
il va se retirer
il va falloir attendre que les nouvelles
institutions dote la république d'un
sénat pour que l'on se préoccupe
effectivement de me trouver une place
officielle et les neuf dernières années
de sa vie
il siègera au sénat on l'appelle pas
d'ailleurs dans la presse de l'époque le
poète sénateurs quand on lit le poète
sénateurs pas besoin de le nommer c'est
victor hugo qui siège à l'extrême gauche
du sénat aujourd'hui une plaque sur son
siège
et c'est au sénat qui va prononcer ces
derniers grands discours politique mais
c'est vrai que finalement il restera
toute sa vie un parlementaire il a
commencé à la chambre des pairs qui déjà
siégé au palais du luxembourg
il termine au sénat entre temps il a eu
des mandats relativement éphémère de
représentants du peuple et de mère
entrait en 1848 aussi dans quelques
jours et est très symboliquement ilna il
n'accepte pas il n'accède pas au pouvoir
suprême
en revanche c'est vrai que quand on
demande aujourd'hui de citer un grand
républicain du 19e siècle le nom de
victor hugo arrive tout de suite à
l'esprit est ce que moi j'ai voulu faire
c'est me replonger dans sa pensée
parce que finalement
le paradoxe est aujourd'hui on trouve
très facilement les romans les poèmes
les pièces de théâtre de victor hugo
dans toute librairie ya au moins une
édition poche avec un livre de victor
hugo
il est très difficile de trouver ces
textes politiques alors lui-même a voulu
les éditer sous le titre actes et
paroles mais il a cédé à ce petit
penchant pour tous les hommes politiques
cette coquetterie qui consista à
maquiller un petit peu à réécrire les
textes politiques et donc ils se
présentent beaucoup à son avantage ils
coupent des interruptions mal son nom
moi je me suis plongée vraiment dans les
comptes-rendus originale chaque fois que
victor hugo s'exprimer un compte rendu
officiel qui paraît à une époque au
moniteur plus tard au journal officiel
on voit là je me suis concentré sur ces
textes là sur des documents originaux et
j'ai voulu extraire tout ce qui pouvait
avoir une résonance aujourd'hui et sur
99 points aussi variés que la
vivisection la propriété industrielle
l'europe la monnaie l'école la laïcité
on trouve un victor hugo qui a des
choses vraiment à nous dire aujourd'hui
encore c'est ça qui m'a intéressé c'est
de reconstituer à la fois son parcours
d'homme politique
on oublie qu ça a été un homme politique
important même s'il n'est pas aller
aussi haut qu'il aurait voulu aller et
puis c'est un homme politique qui n'est
pas simplement un politicien c'est un
homme qui a incarné une certaine idée de
la république
il n'a exprimé de façon assez détaillée
et je trouve est totalement injuste que
ces textes soient très difficiles à
retrouver aujourd'hui
donc j'ai voulu les rassembler dans une
partie un peu anthologie qui termine ce
livre on voit d'ailleurs à quel point
c'était un visionnaire c'est à la fois
un contestataire mais tous les
contestataires
ne change pas le monde même si le monde
quand ils changent c'est toujours
l'oeuvre des contestataires mais il ya
des contestataires qui sont des
visionnaires et c'est le cas de et c'est
le cas de victor hugo il est assez
extraordinaire mais je me demande si je
n'avais pas eu il n'a pas eu raison trop
tôt
au fond aujourd'hui de m délire ou de
donner des responsabilités politiques à
un humoriste en italie où un animateur
de télé réalité aux états unis où un
ancien acteur comme ronald reagan ou ou
un moment on a pensé en france que yves
montand pourrait devenir notre ronald
reagan
alors qu'il est souvent fatale son look
sur le caddy montant mais on dit victor
hugo là ça méritait quand même là ça
méritait la question c'est est ce que
vous pensez
s'il avait été élu est ce qu'il aurait
été aussi génial qu'il l'était en tant
que visionnaire mais à ce moment là
évidemment libres de toute contrainte
n'ayant pas les mains dans le cambouis
je pense qu'il serait une expérience
politique extraordinaire elle n'aurait
peut-être pas eu une grande durée je
pense que hugo est quelqu'un qui aurait
pu lancer 2
grande réforme il en avait l'idée avant
tout le monde s'il avait eu le sens
politique profiter du moment trouver des
alliés pour avoir une majorité ils
auraient pu faire gagner pas mal de
temps à la france ne serait ce que sur
la démocratisation de l'école ou sur
l'abolition de la peine de mort ça c'est
certain
son rival lamartine au fond un bien
passé trois mois aux pouvoirs en 1848 et
c'est aussi un poète et un écrivain qui
se retrouvent là pour le coup aux
manettes gouvernementale donc pourquoi
pas victor hugo il lui a manqué
peut-être un sens politique que
lamartine avait avait davantage
peut-être aurait-il été impopulaire au
bout d'un certain temps
le grand paradoxe et de sa chance et
peut-être d'être resté en lisière du
pouvoir c'est à dire d'avoir et au fond
c'était son projet initial le mage
l'inspirateur il a finalement indiqué
l'horizon il a discerné un petit peu
l'idéal à atteindre il l'a formulée il a
exprimé il a propagé auprès de plusieurs
générations de républicains et ça
continue peut être encore aujourd'hui
de ce point de vue là il a oeuvré s'il
avait eu lui même à mettre en oeuvre ses
réformes peut-être que comme tout homme
politique qui se serait fait trop
d'ennemis il aurait perdu à un moment
une maj de sa majorité ou son soutien
populaire c'est possible une expérience
politique gaullienne aurait peut-être
été un petit peu douloureuse elle ne
sait pas trouver ce qui s'est trouvée
c'est un grand écrivain qui s'est jeté
dans l'arène qui s'est présenté au
suffrage plusieurs fois été élu et dont
il nous reste de très bon discours de
très beaux textes et des discours qui ne
sont pas du tout creux suis toujours
peiné quand j'entends dire oui victor
hugo ça ronronne ça sonne bien mais il
n'y a pas de fonds c'est totalement faux
c'est vraiment une idée reçue
hugo est très profond en fait et je
crois aussi que là où il a été très
exigeant en tant qu'homme politique
c'est qu'ils ne voulaient pas d'un
mandat pour un mandat ils voulaient ils
prenaient très au sérieux le moindre de
ses discours le moindre de ses courriers
d'hommes politiques et au fond ils
avaient conscience d'incarner une forme
de futurs une forme de société qui était
en train d'accoucher d'une manière ou
d'une autre et lui aurait voulu être
l'acteur principal 1 2 de cette
naissance la merci bruno fuligni victor
hugo président ça vient de paraître chez
biblis et une facettes nouvelles de
victor hugo et moi en ce qui me concerne
je les ranger dans la bibliothèque à
victor hugo il est entre ses poésies son
théâtre et ses romans puisque c'est une
véritable partie de son oeuvre
merci à tous et 2 merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]